dogs my whole life and one of the things
that you do is I right now have a golden
retriever we have a yeah we have a white
black yeah yeah hello lab and I've had a
bunch of different dogs I've had
Mastiffs and pit bulls and German
Shepherds no small we have a dachshund -
you don't have small my oldest daughter
has a tiny Chihuahua it's a piece off
sorry no he's the best
they bark all the time though now he
doesn't bark that much he brought us a
little bit but he's really smart he's
actually a mutt he's Chihuahua and
Australian Shepherd but he's like that
big he's the best but my point being is
that you can see if you get a dog from a
breeder you really can see how they can
cultivate certain types of behavior like
yeah it's a good example of my Mastiff
who passed away this year he came from
this guy who bred dogs for films and for
police training and he was the most calm
most chilled out dog I've ever had in my
life he was a giant dog he's 140 pounds
but he you could have him taken anywhere
and trust him with a baby and he was a
COO like everything was like totally
heat but this guy purposely any time a
dog showed any aggression towards people
or any aggression towards dogs he
wouldn't let him breathe so how can
anyone know here are the stories like
that or no stories like that and not
then also think that genes play a role
in human behavior oh they do you have
children yes you realize that when you
have children you see like okay this is
not I didn't do this this is cut this
comes from me yes there's certain traits
that my children have that I watch and I
go okay this is not this isn't teach
them yes they just are easy way they
were born this we've got my fucked up
brain you know there's something in
there they're not seeing the like they
don't see how crazy I am in terms of
like how hard are working things they
how obsessive I get with things they're
just doing and it's very weird it's very
weird because you see yo oh okay well
how much of this shit that's in me is
well how much of me is me deciding to be
this person and how much of me has no
choice about half and half I would say
mmm overall on average across traits how
much do you think gets passed down
through genetics and terms
inclinations like like the new
transition yes about half on average so
for example about half the very you know
how religious you are or how risk-averse
you are like I can I can about half the
variation and how if you look at a group
of people and some are more risk-averse
than others about about half of that has
to do with their genes and half has to
do with how they were raised or what
environments they grew up in so you know
there's a kind of an anus to many of our
qualities and you can shape them you
know for example you can't you couldn't
make me a musician unfortunately I have
almost no musical talent I can dance I
think I mean I think others would even
say that I can do that but so it's not
just like I think I can dance but I
can't but I have no musical ability
whatsoever I would say I'm tone-deaf and
and you know I can appreciate music I
like I mean but I can't produce it
there's no way you could train me I
don't think to be a musician but so some
of it is inborn and some of it is is is
taught for all of these qualities yes
it's a fascinating thing to watch it
emerge from a child isn't it yes as a
parent you see where it comes from
although we have adopted like I my
mother had three biological children and
I have two adopted siblings that come
from actually a multiracial family I
have a black sister and a Chinese
brother
and my mother was an incredible human
being she died when I was 25 she was 47
and we have been foster parents my wife
and I and so and might we have lots of
adopted kids in the extended family in
addition to biological kids and so you
can see you can see the play of genes
you can see the extent to which the the
kind of the inherited traits that these
people that we all have and you see the
shaping by how you're raised and you
know so both are important and this is
incidentally why if you ever have anyone
it's not it's not nature or nurture it's
both yeah always almost in every single
trait actually well that's the case of
so many things in this life we wanted
everything to be by an area yes it's
it's nuts
yeah it's a total we were talking
earlier it's a total loss of nuance and
an inability to see any gray and and and
some people think and I think that's
what you were talking about
some people think that we are hard-wired
to like dichotomies to see you know male
and female and and up and down and good
and evil and left and right and to
simplify the world by finding it and
that we like it that in soothing to us
to think that the world can be divided
into two categories but in fact many
times not always like up and down is
sort of clear right but many times it
can't there shades of gray and it's
harder that's harder to live in the gray
yes I completely agree and that's why
I've always been opposed I mean I get I
think it's incredibly foolish to deny
that but people find comfort in denying
yes they find comfort in being tribal
yes find comfort in them yeah us versus
them yes is the classic yes yes yes it's
it's a it's a simplified view of the
world and it's it's foolish and
dangerous actually yeah
now sometimes you're at war with an
enemy you know it's me or him and or us
or them there are circumstances in which
it's a different survival yes your level
in that mode yes I get it but but you
know but I think a kind of worldview
which says we are good they are evil as
that we've been saying in different kind
of ways in different parts of our
conversation is I think foolish and
wrong and ultimately self injurious
actually yeah so